hey guys it's Justine and today we are
unboxing the brand new Mac Pro and two
Pro XD are displays now I wanted this
unboxing to be very special because
obviously the Mac Pro is super powerful
so I rented three 8k rights we have one
two three we're gonna test this thing
out after we have box it of course
[Music]
this thing is so in there oh I can see
it I can see it
[Music]
this honestly thing is not way more than
me I'm not even joking well no maybe not
wishful thinking I'll show you guys the
front of this thing oh yeah this is
great
let's get these monitors opened if
they're an unboxing feature here which
workout do you want to start unboxing oh
[Music]
the executive boxes to look differently
I thought that they would have like the
full screen display the full Mac Pro on
it it's also like a different type of
box it's like a feels more of a higher
quality like plastic we've got one more
monitor oh my gosh you're so beautiful
it's such a nice minimalist design it's
got a really dust riyal handle here too
and now for this fans even they have a
little pull tab dual monitors baby I
decided to go with the mat monitors I'm
mostly because my office is very
reflective when I have the windows and
stuff open so I thought this would be a
really great change of pace
[Music]
that was not even the unboxing yet that
was just unboxing the box that I need to
unbox this is a 32 inch retina 6k
display with 10-bit color a thousand
it's full screen brightness 1600 nits of
peak brightness which makes working with
HDR content way more accurate we're in a
box one of the stands first and then a
monitor cuz I'm gonna be using the Mac
Pro to unbox these things I will say
that the experience of unboxing this so
far has been amazing like the texture on
the box the design the fabric little
handle here and of course Apple doesn't
require a knife this just pops open like
that I mean even the stand is an
enjoyable unboxing feels like there
should be something in this but there's
not look inside this is way bigger than
I thought even though I saw it at WGC
I've been waiting for a new Apple
monitor for so long you can't tell we
currently turn to my living room into a
nice little office also got some
directions probably going to actually
read the instructions for the first time
in my life knowledge has been seeped
into my brain let's open up this monitor
it's packaged in like a little blanket
okay so this just folds down I can't
believe that this is I'm touching this
right now I can't believe this is my
house
wait do I turn this round for you you
guys look at this oh my goodness
really does look like a cheese grater
like there is no way around that like a
hundred percent but I love it looks like
he's got a little bandaid on its the
Apple logo they protected the Apple logo
with this little sticker so I think that
the installation is pretty simple it's
really isn't that heavy either wait is
it on is it in so this monitor guided
itself on to the stand I didn't even do
anything like I was just sort of in the
vicinity you are so freaking beautiful
don't ever let anybody tell you that you
are not worth a thousand dollars don't
let them tell you that because you're
worth it
I smell so good it smell so it smells
like how like a fresh winter day
I'm so glad I decided to get the mat
version it's been a really long time
since I've had a mat screen and this is
super exciting because I shoot a lot of
videos and I'm always shooting my screen
so to be able to have a matte screen
with almost zero reflections is going to
be amazing we have one display ready I'm
gonna be editing all of mines organs
stories like this from now on
this is incredible there's a little
switch in the back here so you just
flick that and lock locked look at this
okay let's see what else is in this box
so we've got some more instructions here
so here's the pro display XD our booklet
this is about like a nice paper like
this is something that I would put on my
bookshelf
[Music]
monitors are all set up now it's time to
do the unboxing MacPro oh my gosh I
can't believe this is actually the time
is now this box itself is just a piece
of work like this has a Velcro here on
the side it has them on both sides like
this is a perfectly onion ear box
[Music]
weather chart this is going to include a
mouse and keyboard or not mouse keyboard
trackpad this is the extended keyboard
as well
it's the matte black mouse no this is a
black mouse Maddy come see this this is
an all-new Mouse because the other one
is like a more of a space grey color
this is something that I don't think
that they even talked about and a black
trackpad hold on a second I'm processing
my emotions look at this I need to go
grab the space grey one because you guys
got to see the color difference oh gosh
I know we're burning through that red
footage I'm gonna go as fast as I can
okay
the trackpad obviously extremely
different here's the mouse it's more of
a little bit of a glare color look like
a new kind of a hue to it this is the
new Mouse completely black come see
these color differences I know you're a
dog and you can't see colors goodbye
oh my god it's really happy here's
inside the box I'm glad this gives you
the instructions on how to open the box
after you've already opened it power
cable and I think that's it this box is
so well designed I mean you need to
protect this thing in transit obviously
Danny this could be your new home I
cannot wait to get wheels on this thing
Apple logo it's massive spin this around
so you can get a real nice shot of this
this beautiful Maddy what do you think
don't think that I have been dying to
try out is lifting up the top of this so
it gives you easy access to the internal
configuration so if we need to do any
upgrades which at this point I'm not
sure why you would because let's say
you're so powerful already you just turn
and lift
[Music]
it is just so beautiful
I want to show you guys a side-by-side
comparison of the old macro tower and
the new one it's really crazy to see
what this looks like
up next to this new one it was actually
over ten years ago that I won this thing
in the price is right you guys probably
think I'm joking I'm not so the old one
side just popped right off still pretty
impressive design of this one of way
heavier for sure we changed up our angle
a little bit and now we're gonna finally
plug this thing in and get these
monitors all fired up Mac Pro this is
the power cable 90 that's old tech don't
look at it okay finally plugging this
thing in we got to get this thing set up
look at the back of this thing it's so
beautiful now let's get these
Thunderbolt cables plugged in to the
monitors I think that's it
cable management oh not so good three
two one
can you look look so we have we have
something happening it is floating up
over here shutting the screen can you
see it okay we okay is everything okay
is everyone okay am i okay
I'm not sure everything is it's working
next we've got both of them set up each
one of these monitors can go up to 1600
nits of brightness we have two of them
side by side now I need to get this
thing all set up so that I can start to
edit night mode Catalina daytime
Catalina
it's great because I have two little
desktop options here for each display I
am so excited to edit I've never been
this excited to edit anything in my
entire life the brightness is all the
way up you can see here there's
different display options so this one
says Pro display 1600 nits so I still
need to download everything I basically
have nothing on this computer except to
whatever iCloud is automatically
downloading I need to get final cut and
you can press her Photoshop in here and
then we're gonna copy all of this red
footage over I do have a 4 terabyte
drive and we've shot how much stuff will
be shot already today almost Board of
terabytes so there is an option to go up
to 8 terabytes but this is only the 4
terabyte option so I'm probably gonna
have to also edit some footage off
solid-state drive which I normally do
anyway so that's totally fine cuz we're
gonna also be shooting some more footage
tomorrow I'm probably gonna bring my
server downs but I can edit directly off
of that because these Reds are just
eating up the space one of the
highlights of Mac Pro especially for
Final Cut editors which I am one is if
you have Pro res raw 8k footage you can
simultaneously add it up to 6 strings
which is pretty impressive you can
connect up to 6 of the protis play x-ers
to the Mac Pro but if you have 4k
monitors you can connect 16 of them so I
think everything is now officially
downloaded and we can start transferring
it with
[Music]
we are now down here in Santa Monica I
wanted to bring you guys here this is
where I shoot all of my review videos
but I wanted to shoot some b-roll and
that's an 8k footage to use while I'm
editing because I don't really have any
but now I do okay Jesse and I know
you're editing this right now let's cut
to something to b-roll that we just shot
while we're down here
[Music]
[Applause]
this is the area that made me want to
move here and this is also the home of
one of my favorite Apple stores I have a
lot of memories here I slept outside
here for 55 plus hours for the iPhone 6
you guys may have seen that video but
this place has a very special place in
my heart in my life and especially
[Music]
so haven't quite figured out how I'm
gonna set these monitors when I start
editing but I have some footage already
over here and it looks so incredible I
cannot wait to start editing which I'm
gonna do I guess right now so I will see
you guys later and wish me luck because
I'm probably gonna be here all night I
can't believe how good this footage
looks what time do you guys want to
start tomorrow
9 o'clock maybe earlier do you think
maybe he's healing one light on you did
you eat all the pizza honey what are
they going
[Music]
see you later
Sanna Sanna I know now
[Music]
you are the one
so we're back for my night of editing
which was more like a few hours about it
because I fell asleep but I got a few
things edited here but what we have
going on is I'm editing this all in an
aching timeline so previously we were
shooting red code five to one
compression and I realized that the
compression rate was super high and it
was eating up storage space so quickly
so we switched it for the rest of the
shoot we're now shooting 10:00 to 1:00
so that's giving us much more time to
record and a lot more storage space here
we go
this is it I play this for you but you
already saw this edited in this video so
when I click in here you'll see that I
have this in a multicam timeline and I'm
able to quickly and easily switch
between camera shots so this monitor I'm
using is an AV output which is super
easy to do you just click a V output and
this is basically being used as our
display monitor currently at the time of
shooting this I'm not entirely done
editing this yet it's still a rough edit
so many of you guys are probably
wondering what the specs are of this
computer so this is obviously the Mac
Pro this is the 2.5 gigahertz 28 core
Intel processor which is so insane that
this is something that is sitting in my
house right now
this has 384 gigs of memory which can be
upgraded to one point five terabytes
also absolutely insane this has the 4
terabyte solid-state drive my storage is
full no I made a huge mistake by
thinking that I could edit a lot of this
off of the internal so I'm gonna be
exporting all of this on to my jellyfish
server and then editing just with the
library on my internal drive now I'm
never gonna be able to shoot another
YouTube video again unless it's with a
red a K this is a problem
this Mac configuration also has two AMD
Radeon Pro Vega twos plus it's equipped
with an afterburner card this is used to
offload processes to help eliminate the
need of creating proxy footage while
editing really high quality content
thank you guys so much for watching this
video and so much fun shooting this I
hope you guys enjoyed this first look
video here at the new Mac Pro I've been
having so much fun editing this this
video was shot over the course of two
days so at the time of me shooting this
right now I have not got a chance to
fully edit and really experience this
computer so stay tuned for a follow-up
video at some point in the meantime I
hope you guys like this video make sure
you guys give it a thumbs up if you
enjoyed it be sure to subscribe so
you'll see more of my videos and I'm
gonna go and maybe I'll make myself a
good cheese sandwich
hi Maddie good boy you excited about
this mac pro we're gonna unbox it
together okay need a help mommy edit